God do I have to go back in the room
[Laughter]
it's Mark's turn now okay here we go
ahaha man I'll do fair game again
because now that we know the new ones
now we know how they go it'll be easy
right that yeah the [ __ ] Venn diagram
one it's so hard to wrap your head
remember that one being really difficult
to look at oh my god it's it's it's just
a [ __ ] alright but we can do this you
ready yeah let's do it
alright I'm going in for those of you
who are watching at home we are playing
they that don't keep talking and nobody
explodes we are playing they need to
shut up where I'm gonna float all right
normal wires six of them six wires how
many yellows are there Hiro yellows what
is the last digit of the serial number
it is nine cut the third wire okay good
we've got maze alright where are your
circles my good man they're in the same
column top and bottom got you got you
got you where is your white light third
column second row and where is your red
triangle second column six row who's
gonna be a long one you ready ready left
left down down left left up to up to
right three one two three down down
right up up right right down to down to
left left down
down left to left - down down right -
right - damn down left until you hit the
triangle spaces yes
all right we've got big number for small
numbers big number for small numbers
I'm ready what's it say - press the
button in the second position that is it
- okay for press the button in the same
position as stage one so second position
alright that is a three
one press the button with the same label
you press in stage 2 so 3 ok there's
another I me as 3 heads in the fourth
position so for now press the button in
the same position as stage 2 which was
second position second position ok last
one is a four same label you pressed in
stage 3 I believe that was a three yes
oh yeah
good we're good okay we've got the five
letters arrows up and down where are you
ok ok ok go through your first letters
let's get we have we've got e K V X I
our e and the only one is ok it's there
every or right ok so if you have a V in
the second column we've got every we've
got V so e V ery is that possible yes ok
it's good yeah ok
alright one more on the back we've got
the shoelaces ki dokie
first black is going in to be cut it
second black going into a cut it ok
third black going in to see donut fourth
black going in to be do not cut ok first
blue going into a do not cut second blue
going into C cut it ok third blue going
into beat cut it first red going into B
do not cut a fifth black going to C do
not cut okay we're good we did it we did
with a minute and one left
whoa
we're gonna be good yeah I'm getting
like cramps now this is not good I need
to relax
it's more stressful being on the manual
that is be actually what I did that time
is I physically touched my computer
screen and kept my finger on the number
of the whichever color just so I did
because I was like I'm gonna forget one
of these okay all right
that was great man those great let's do
pick up the pace Oh No 30 seconds oh how
many muscles all right let's do this
okay I'm so ready for this we have got
this in a big way all right we're
looking at no it's blank we're looking
at regular wires we got six of them all
right are there any yellows one yellow
are there any White's no whites are
there any Reds three Reds cut the fourth
wire good
we got symbols okay what do you got
candelabra Omega train track six okay
six track candelabra Omega got it okay
we've got a white button oh Sh the
snooze button we've got a white button
that says detonate how many batteries
are on the thing we've got one battery
all right
is there a label with CR next to a light
ciear
no does that no it's a no big papa
sorry press and hold press an old press
okay we got yellow release when there's
a five in any position Oh God it's as
far away from a five it could possibly
be it's fine it's good it's totally fine
we've got a minute and 15 seconds woo
with detonator
okay blue support nope if there's more
no good no no no no hold press and hold
okay we've got a yellow 5 in any
position okay we've got the six word
buttons in the big word if we've got
yeah okay that what is the big word
display bottom right what's it say
you're with an apostrophe okay hit it
when you hear the first word ready you
you're with an apostrophe the letters
you are good okay
go faster we've got this play bottom
right a-hole okay
you space are the letter U we're done
you are as in the words you on are you
at you and are the words okay got it
alright last one we've got Oh fifteen
seconds read read re D bottom left no
blank wait first got it totally did it
now that no problem everything under
control
now that nail that nailed it oh gosh oh
[Laughter]
okay one more hey I opened up Section
four okay wait we've got a small wrinkle
what something is different about this
bomb and it demands attention like that
that's not good that's not good right
here we go let's do it boys
we've got six modules I don't know what
the new mod
you want to start with the new module
sure all right whatever it is oh okay
it's got like it's got like squiggly
wires a knob that's like a big crank a
little meter on the left
Oh God oh sweet Christ it's got like it
looks squiggly wires yeah okay okay
discharge the capacitor before it
overloads by holding down the lever do
it now
sure yeah okay okay we just need to keep
that discharge and we need to keep
coming back to it and discharging it oh
okay all right then we've got normal
wires how many we've got five okay five
lawyers is the last wire black yes is
the digit of the serial number odd it is
yes cut the fourth wire done we've got
funkalicious wires do I just come back
to that and just press it I don't know
let's do fun collisions a Venn diagram
wires yeah all right what do you got
we've got a red no one yes LED no star
okay no star yes LED you be means just
the bomb if two or more batteries it's
got to cut that one you got it
next one's way white no LED yes star yes
star totally on top of this don't worry
about it yes LED no LED no LED yes star
C means cut it okay got it
next one's red and white no LED no star
what is the last digit of the serial
number it is a one don't cut it
okay XY blue and red no LED yes star yes
star no LED P is for is there a parallel
port yes
cut it cut next one's white yes LED no
star
it's wrong they're bad D is for do not
cut okay all right um yeah oh yeah it
was good sorry the green lit up okay we
got okay good regular button says hold
blue blue button says hold press the
hold okay we got white release with a
one in any position yeah got it
okay all right we got try we got symbols
symbols many symbols make it we got
triangle squid head with a T jutting out
of it
we got a paragraph we got a question
mark upside down we got a B with a T in
it all right
paragraph yep BT yep squid yep question
mark got it alright we've got one more
regular wire six of them
alright six wires are there any yellow
capacitor
no yellow got the third wire third we're
dead 1.06 baby not so bad you just got
to go back to it so did you discharge
the capacitor that room it had like it
started up like at three minutes and
then we had a 45 second counter so hmm
pretty good hey we're in the top 82
percent hey that's that's a lot of
percents that's good wait a minute this
other person's top 95 percent but they
had less time so is it oh you want to be
in the top 1% oh yeah you want to be in
a lower post oh this is bad
that's not we're not in oh all right
well your turn to bat my friend oh goody
your turn to really show us what you got
oh god sakes okay what you gonna do all
right have you unlocked section three
yet yes okay got you oh no I haven't
unlocked section four yet nevermind
well we can we can do do some other
section 31 sue that's speedy pick up the
pace - I can't promise you I'm gonna
guide you through this okay
Hey bumbum finished with 6.3 seconds
left
yeah like we were just doing that I'm so
ready dude my my hands regular wires
only three of them all right there any
Reds one red okay is the last wire white
yes cut that one dunzo Simba is my boy
symbols read them I've been upside down
question mark you know with a dick a
backwards E with eyes and like an O with
a lot of extra squiggle coming around
inside there okay all right go for the e
the dick yep the O squiggle and the
question mark all right
another symbols ready Oh with a dick
dick a on top of a teeth thing lambda
with a cross hatch and then squid squid
boy with a T coming out of them
impressive right as you read them to me
Oh a lambda squid done button man you're
good at this yellow button that says
hold my good man how many batteries two
two two two batteries two batteries it
was white yellow okay never mind
all right just press and hold white one
look for a one tons o last ones amazed
all right well my first chance at amaze
both circles are in the far left column
top row and then 4th row got it where's
your triangle is in or the white square
is in the second column fifth row and
the triangle is in the second column
second row okay all right
I'm just gonna read them out you blast
through let's fast as you want up up up
up right down done
come on completely 30 4.4 seconds left
on that [ __ ] that's the top 27% and
better than everyone on my friends list
[ __ ] those guys that c-grade sort of
performance there that's pretty good
that's a level C bomb defusal I'll take
all credit for that and I'll take all
credit I'll take all credit
nailed it hironao and rocked I unlocked
for apparently okay it's pretty to get
rocked feel free to do as hard as you
want I want to do this one because of
the name but I'm afraid of what it means
we're gonna play the knob the knob meaty
knobs need the most attention five
minutes six modules only one oopsies
[Laughter]
what do I do for the needy knob is it
bad yeah alright what do I do about the
needy knobs okay the knob can be turned
to one of four different positions that
knob must be in the correct position
when this modules
timer hits zero the correct positions
can be determined by the on-off
configuration of the twelve LEDs knob
position oh my god all right let's do
symbols let's burn through some similar
okay okay okay okay okay
but I mean we'll probably have to get
back to that yeah I'll keep an eye on it
go for or go for symbols backwards end
with a hat and a foot candelabra train
tracks backwards II with some eyeballs
okay go for e train tracks candelabra n
another symbol copyright and are with no
left stick yeah a big X with an eye in
it uh-huh and then a Oh with an extra
swoopy swoop okay copyright Oh scoop X I
know alright the kneading Ava's on
alright
needing up okay what are the lights tell
me is the first top left one lit no okay
yes yes it is lit okay so is the is the
top right one lid no okay
is the bottom left one lit yes okay move
it to the right position what is the
position it was in what it was in the
right position
no oriented from Oh from up [ __ ] that
was I was actually about to guess that I
should have clicked it uh it's okay oh
[ __ ] okay I should have got to the knob
faster I didn't realize how involved
that was gonna be that's okay I'm gonna
go blow my nose because I'm gonna
explode all over my microphone and we're
gonna try this again Hank well it's just
you and me guys so hi
just just us I'm all drained it's not
alright good good good I cannot vamp on
my own
dude I don't do well it's just awkward
silence I heard that I just don't do
well by myself like you can't you can't
just leave me like that
alright regular wires sir okay what wait
what wait what oh my god whoa hey hey
whoa hey we're starting I wasn't ready
um okay or the red wire jeez all right
cut the second wire good symbols sorry I
thought all right top left is it lit yes
all right bottom left no okay how about
the third column top No third column
bottom is it lit no okay
down position okay that should be good
it's ready to go
let's do symbols all right lay them on
me Oh with a dick ah question mark
upside down Oh with an extra squiggle
okay and an H with an extra foot okay Oh
dick Oh squiggle h eight-foot question
more symbols not color dead star Oh with
an extra squiggle most of an R and what
looks like a butt with an eyeball over
it go but eyeball Oh squiggle R star
done Zoe's okay we've got complicated
wires with the Stars and the LEDs okay
ready first one is red with an LED no
star okay no Mimi Tina video yeah top
left lit lit okay
bottom left not lit not lit okay third
column bottom not lit okay down again
leave it down okay it's fine the way it
is okay go back two wires red red yes
LED no star red yes LED no star okay uh
how many batteries - no batteries at all
okay no batters how does it have a
what's this last digit of the serial
number six
okay uh cut it okay the next one is good
huh huh huh what do we die
what did a needy knob happen no the
needy knob was fun
oh it's only oh I must said goofed
something I'm sorry I have closed the
wires that goofed us I apologize
god damn this is hard it's really hard
Jesus I'm sorry I apologize
that's why it's so hard
I have never messed up in this game how
I don't know who I am anymore
okay be alone try that one again or try
a less hard one we can do that it was
just beyond the wires I don't know what
I did let's do symbols let's burn
through the symbols all right Oh God
we're going why do you keep you don't
say when you're starting okay don't
restart it all restart no it's fine
what was that one now it's called the
knob that's right art it's loading now
you're ready I don't know when you're
going gonna jump scare you all right
let's symbols backwards paragraph smiley
face candelabra and a backwards three
with antennas candelabra smiley face
paragraph three done let's do another
symbols no needy knobs needy now just
going top left aa lit okay
bottom left lit okay how about the top
right lit okay right position okay
symbols then yes no with an extra
squiggle an e backwards with eyeballs Oh
with a dick and an H that's all squiggly
e eyeballs Oh dick Oh squiggle H all
right six wires six wires regular wires
yeah regular wire six of them how many
yellows two
red wires no cut the last wire done
needy knob all right top left not lit
not lit okay uh bottom left lit okay
second top so like second column second
column yet top lit down position okay
done words six words with the word
display oh okay
ready says says bottom right left okay
we've got right left first
dun dun dun okay display says no no
bottom right uh [ __ ] I can't read it
what does that say right right okay
we've got yes nothing ready press on
display says display okay bottom right
you why don't you why are you okay
you've got sure you are the words
separated we got your no apostrophe your
with a pot okay that module is done
kneading up okay top or left let okay
bottom left lit okay top right lit right
position that's so loud shut up alarm
clock okay there we go last thing is
complicated wires okay if the stars and
the LEDs all right this time I'm not
gonna [ __ ] up first water is red with an
LED and a star with LED and star yes
don't cut the next wire is blue and
white with no LED and yes star no LED
yes star is there a parallel port yes
cutting I'm a [ __ ] idiot
oh god I'm so
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I'm sorry I keep the Venn
diagram so hard I know it's so hard you
you could go again I'm sorry oh no you
could try one okay I believe all right
okay
oh my god I'm so bad at that
I like how immediate they're the
responses on that it's not like you you
say cut and I cut it and I'm like oh
it's like cut it no I'm dead I'll do
this one called pay attention all right
I'm here to pay attention I'm ready to
listen bleah I'm ready to listen to you
pay attention starting I'm hit I hit the
start button all right let's do this
so you know I want to make sure you know
and around here I appreciate that I
should do that for you as well okay all
right and the lights are on
okay we've got a capacitor thing so that
should be easy to take okay just try
reading that okay we've got symbols hit
me six train tracks and with a hat
encyclopedia a e six train tracks a II
got it
the last one you said we've got Simon
Says yeah all right flashing red is the
serial number contain a vowel no okay
not contain eval Fasching red no strikes
blue correct it's now red green blue
green
got it red green green blue green green
I'm just gonna wait for confirmation
anyway just do the case on that thing
red green green red blue green green red
got it draining the capacitor blue green
green blue got it okay on the other side
we've got the button white with detonate
button is nope is there more than one
battery on the bomb there is two
batteries press and immediately release
got it
there's numbers with four numbers yeah
yeah yeah okay what number is on the
first one one second raining real quick
all right we've got a 1 press the button
in the second position
that is a three we've got a 1 press the
button labeled 4 got it that's in the
first position a hang on I got drained
okay four we've got a four press the
button labeled four okay that's in the
fourth position so it's been three four
four we've got a three press the button
in the same position as you pressed in
stage two okay in the same position yes
okay that's those first position got it
all right we've got a one press the
button with the same label you pressed
in stage one which is a three yeah okay
got it done yay whoa really
what do you mean really really we add
that we nailed that yeah nailed that
yeah probably because one of us can read
the instructions correctly probably I
just imagine we're top 19% in that one
top 19 that's pretty good you cut out a
little bit there were you talking there
yeah it's pretty good all right we've
now I've opened up section five oh god
no no wait section five wait oh that's
not a good section
these are not fun is it okay
there's wires wires everywhere it's a
rat nest cut carefully
there's computer hacking no no oh my god
computer hacking is eight modules one
strike pick up the pace you got four
modules in a minute thirty four pick up
the pace oh god I'll just do wires wires
everywhere let's try that that sounds
fun and safe we can do wires right no
yeah why is this easy it's not the fun
diagram one easy it'll be it'll be the
Venn diagram one all right I'm in lights
are coming on we got normal wires six of
them six normal wires let's do this are
there any yellow wires one yellow how
many white wires are there zero
are there any red wires four of them cut
the fourth wire done next is Moore's
regular wire six of them two yellows but
are there any Reds two Reds cut the
fourth wire all right easy peasy
all right we've got the we've got the
occurrence wires first yeah first good
okay first red going into C cut it cut
it
all right we've got second red going
into C don't cut first blue into a don't
cut second blue into C cut got it third
blue into be cut third read into B don't
cut for thread into a cut it fourth blue
into B do not cut uh fifth red and no
six red into a oh [ __ ] I don't remember
you're good you're good don't cut don't
cut all right we're gonna that one the
lights have gone out but I am
persevering we've got another occurrence
wire if I could only see what it is I
would okay first red in to see cut it
first blackened to see cut it all right
first blue in to be cut it second red in
to see cut it no
way way way too late I know but we got
we got we got strikes okay ii blue into
in to see i'm keeping track of the
numbers you okay alright first black
into a cut it third read into a cut it
okay the next blue into a do not cut a
next black into a cut it nope oh oh [ __ ]
alright but that we're good on that one
so we just got one last chance for the
Venn diagrams ready oh god okay I'm
ready
alright we got blue with an LED no star
it blue with an LED D do not cut okay
we've got a red with an LED and a star
red star LED be cut if it has two or
more batteries does it have two or more
better oh it's just loaded with
batteries alright cut that one alright
next one's red no LED and a star red
star no LEDs c is for cut that one got
it alright we're good next one's same
deal we've got blue LED and a star blue
LED and the star there's their parallel
port looking looking looking no parallel
port do not cut okay next one is same
thing so do not cut next one is blue and
red no LED and a star same thing no
parallel port don't cut okay next one's
white with a star so it must be cut
right yeah it's the last one cut it
[Applause]
those three wire ones yeah okay yeah all
right hey top 80 second percent that's
good not but you know sounds good yeah
okay top sounds pretty good right yeah I
like that yeah that's good
I don't like this ambiguity and bombs or
a dangerous combination we'll just do
that one going in three minutes and
thirty on this one not a lot of time oh
oh thank you thank you Amy brought me
food
Oh God okay click start yeah okay we've
got nothing but the word things it's all
the word with six words - lead lead led
le ad and lead bottom right hold oh why
aren't these now chuckle okay ready you
space are the letter U done Oh got it
okay next there th e ir middle right
right yes nothing
nailed it okay we've got there again the
same thing middle right like why you're
with an apostrophe next the letter U the
letter Johnny about it okay
continuing you are two words okay bottom
right no blank got it oh all right we've
got a yes
middle left ah with three H's already
know gotten lead lead led right
you are one word two letters done the
letter U the letters you are God ha okay
we've got okay okay okay
top right first less
okay got it yes we've got you why oh you
you middle right like you're with an
apostrophe next the letter you the
goddess you are
we've got C just the letter C this is
the letter C top right uh UHU H two
words the letters you are the letter U
the word John you are all right we've
got display bottom right you are one
word two letters done two letter Johnny
the letters you are okay we've got Cee
Cee Cee Cee nob SEC bottom right bottom
right but or you are done like got it
you okay we've got you y ou you middle
right you're with an apostrophe you
you're with an apostrophe got letters
you are okay Jesus Oh God so good no
worries got it we had 22 seconds left
oh wow okay so you were being very
casual as you watch the countdown oh
yeah actually I didn't see it anymore so
I was okay do you wanna you wanna switch
so I can eat sure cool I'll definitely
be paying attention super well oh yeah
of course it will
why wouldn't it well it's probably gonna
be hard but I guess I want to try the
one we haven't done in section 4 which
was that multitasker that doesn't sound
fun six modules one strike five minutes
description is an extra arm would really
help here get your food stations so
you're ready to read scroll multitasking
right yeah chick-fil-a
ah oh
work good good if you die I'll let you
do it I'm confident I'm generous like
that I'm so right I've got darkness I
have two capacitors holy [ __ ]
fine all right I've got symbols let's do
symbols all right lay them on me wait
wait that guess what guess why Vic oh
yes or no is what I have
it just says respond to the computer
prompts by pressing Y for yes or and for
no death that's all it says
do I wanna vent gas I think so okay yes
venting complete okay done let's do
symbols then I guess go for it I have
the backwards paragraph candelabra
colored and star and smiley face okay
candelabra smiley face backwards
paragraph star all right I've got the
occurrence of wires one okay first black
wires going into C card out that first
blue wires going into a don't done next
we have the second black wire into what
a day sorry sorry
next we have the first red wire into a
don't gotcha
next panel is the next red wire into a
don't the next red wire into c don't the
next blue wire into a caught alright
done next red wire into B don't okay and
then the next blue wire into C don't
okay
Danzo next panel is five letters where
we can change the letters okay first
options for first letter are hey I'm
doing capacitors man these things are
annoying yeah ops is for first letter RC
n PL o G okay it could be P o or L
second letter I have a are X B n Z law
large large large yeah got you got you
got you got you got you got you don't
have that don't have that what large l
lr lar
GE yeah ocean have an r oh [ __ ] wait
what was this option for the second one
again um the second one can be a our xB
+ Z oh my god what was the first one
again go for a first again L Oh G
C and P okay can the come the second
letter did you say there was a
possibility for an O in the second one I
believe so yes good try could oh there's
no oh gosh no whoa
I oh my god just think about it you got
time you got time what go for the first
one again uh hang on venting gas the
first one can be P L o G C and try great
grea t yeah yeah done holy [ __ ] I had
two capacitors and the stupid gas
venting thing going on that whole time
Jesus Christ I don't know why everything
I said to you I had to do to its two
other things the whole [ __ ] time I'm
sorry I had to eat my sandwich in the
middle of that really dressed I was so
stressed teamwork am i right good good
good
yeah teamwork everybody thank you I've
got another sandwich you have two
sandwiches yeah that's so many
sandwiches
oh right man all right let's go let's go
for a world let's go for a speed record
I'm gonna go back to an easy issue one
and we're gonna we're gonna see how fast
we can do it okay I'm right four modules
five minutes that's so easy yeah I'm
already in the top twenty two percent so
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
crush this one I know all right chicken
sounds good in your mouth thanks man
good content start I'm so ready all
right
we have wires six of them yellows no
yellows all right is the serial number
last one odd no it's a two okay
are there any red wires three Reds cut
the fourth wire dunzo
we have Simon Says all right are there
any vowels in the serial number yeah
yeah okay it's giving me red blue give
me red red blue blue just giving me red
red red okay
done got it we've got six words with a
word above them okay it says lead led on
the screen led okay just left press all
right you've got right middle does all
right it says you are the letters you
are bottom right you are the letter O
sorry
you are the let oh sorry it was wrong
you are the letters is top left the what
are you okay aha sure next what done all
right
it's a hold on okay bottom right first
left okay done we have a button all
right what's this a blue and it says
hold blue and hold okay how many
batteries for four okay is there a label
that says frk no no okay all right press
and hold tell me what color blue we've
before I'll be a couple seconds we're
gonna end at 304 which i think is way
better than my last time see how good we
are see how good we are
that's very good I think it was a
sandwich definitely the sandwich yeah
we're in the top 2% percent oh yeah top
of my friends list top 2% how you like
that has it taste delicious it's
delicious
thank you for asking that's delicious
[Music]